[Applause]
so I'm going to start with this because
it seems like a crazy number 25 million
Instagram followers is there pressure in
that do you feel like you have to post
at that point yeah I definitely do feel
that but I I also give myself the
Liberty to just like not care that much
good I feel like I'm constantly like I
probably shouldn't say this it's like a
whole separate job I'm like I like
continuously lose followers every time I
post so I feel like I'm been like all
right bye I guess so I'm like maybe it's
better if I just don't remind them that
they're following me and then under the
radar yeah you're you're turning 30 soon
are you excited about this I'm really
excited to turn 30 yeah I'm like 30s are
fun that's what I hear I just feel like
your 30s especially as a woman it's like
really when you come into yourself and
you like stop caring about what other
people think yeah I feel like that's
already coming for me and you know with
Riverdale ending after seven years I'm
like this feels like a really great time
to be turning 30 it's like a new chapter
I'm excited for you I love my 30s that's
fun how do you celebrate you go big or
do you chill um I like to have I'm very
social I like to have like everyone
gather for my birthday um I really want
to have a bounce house birthday for my
30s I love
you I love that I want to just like get
a big bounce house and invite everyone
and have like you know a themed like a
kids themed birthday maybe like you know
yeah some Disney character as like my
cake or something have a petting
zoo exactly I will tell you during Co
like it saved us I ordered on thank you
Amazon I ordered a bounce house cuz my
my kids were going nuts and like we were
just doing homeschooling and all that
stuff with Co the Bounce House saved us
so I applaud a bounce house M you just
on the Bounce House day yeah go get that
energy out and it for you get out of the
house
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home